welcome back to the stronger bioscience
podcast
in today's episode of course we've got
some good news and some feats of
strength but the main portion of today's
episode
is all about research we've got a big
research roundup segment to get you all
caught up
on recent research in the fields of
exercise science and sports nutrition
the topics we cover include optimal
protein intake essential amino acids
meal timing lactate the relationship
between sleep and hunger
and an update on muscle memory on top of
that greg
also discusses a brand new study that
suggested that adding strength phases to
your training
may promote greater hypertrophy and this
study's gotten a lot of attention it's
been discussed a lot in the
evidence-based fitness world
but there are some important details to
consider about that study
before you draw conclusions on the topic
finally to play us out greg and i
discussed some major food controversies
some of which
have very greatly upset me as always
thank you for listening and we hope you
enjoy the show
[Music]
welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast this is your one and only host
eric trexler but today i am joined
by a special temporary guest co-host his
name is greg knuckles greg how are you
doing
doing well how are you i am doing well
um i want to start out with some intro
uh material some announcements here
first of all
thank you sincerely to all of our new
mass subscribers we had a lot of people
sign up to mass during our big black
friday sale
which is awesome it allowed us to raise
a lot of money for the american
foundation for suicide prevention
and it's really exciting to have a lot
of new faces in the
mass community and on the topic of
communities
be sure to join our stronger by science
facebook group and our subreddit uh
those are
some nice online communities where you
can talk about stronger by science stuff
talk about fitness and science and
and all the good stuff in addition to
that be sure to sign up for our mailing
list
um today we've got a big research
roundup we're going to talk about a
bunch of new studies
and you get that type of content when
you sign up for for the mailing list we
like to send out little research updates
and brief concise summaries with some
useful tips so
if you want to join the facebook group
the subreddit or the mailing list i'm
going to include the information for all
that
in the show notes for today's episode
um now before we get into the content
for today obviously thanksgiving was a
couple weeks ago
and uh you know it's a good time to
reflect on
what you're thankful for and and i know
i personally am very thankful for the
opportunity to build
incredible wealth and that's really been
provided by bulksupplements.com
so if you go to bulksupplements.com and
you use the discount code
sbs pod in all caps you save five
percent off of your order
um so you can join me in this
wealth building endeavor five percent
out of time it builds up big time
so uh very thankful to the folks at
bulksupplements.com it's always a
pleasure to sell out every week when we
uh
tip the cap to them oh actually on that
note uh
i have a surprise for you trex what
would that be
so uh i just got word from the mail room
at stronger by science headquarters
international
uh that our first check from bulk
supplements
arrived you're kidding we are literally
dozens of dollars wealthier uh and
since we have now been paid via
something from the podcast
well i was going to say we can call
ourselves professional podcasters
you can now call yourself a professional
podcaster
and i have had the honor of being a
special temporary guest host
to a professional podcaster so that's
that's a new
like pretty exciting line item for my
resume
yeah i mean it kind of i don't want to
be too egotistical but
when i got a phd and decided to be an
assistant blogger
a lot of people um a lot of people gave
me grief but
let's see who's laughing now now that
i'm a professional podcaster
okay so um we like i said we've got
plenty of research to cover today
but before we do that let's get into
some good news so greg
you've got some good news for us yeah so
uh
last episode we actually took a bit of
heat
um because between when we've recorded
the last episode
and when the last episode aired uh there
was some big
positive news on the coven 19 vaccine
front
uh and people were like ah like greg and
eric just
you know being bummers about good news
that
isn't actually good news when there is
actually legitimate good news in the
world
like [ __ ] you dude like it takes it
takes
literal days of sweat and toil
to get this podcast in a publishable
state
that news had not yet surfaced when we
recorded the last episode
but now it has and so that's my good
news
there are three very promising
covet 19 vaccines in the pipeline
seems like one is very very close to
being improved in europe or has been
approved already
and is likely to start rolling out soon
there are two
that they're saying are very close to
being approved in the us
and they're hoping that those can start
being rolled out in the next month or
two
uh so you know seems like
this uh this long nightmare might be
coming to an
end the only way it wouldn't be is if
maybe there was some
less good news about how many people
plan to get the vaccine
oh wait [ __ ] breaking news uh there
was
new uh new data from pew research that
just came out two days ago
asking americans how likely they were to
get
uh a covid 19 vaccine when it comes out
and only 60 of americans say that
they'll either
quote probably or definitely get the
vaccine
uh 21 say probably not in 18
say definitely not and the thing is
uh 60 is
right at the level where it wouldn't be
enough
to to actually start curtailing the
virus
or like to curtail it in a big way if
everything went back to normal
so scientists say that the basic
reproduction rate for covenant 19 is
about 2.5 that's the r naught value if
you were
following epidemiology stuff early in
the pandemic
which basically means that if people are
just going about their lives
and the virus is spreading you know
pretty much unchecked
every person who gets it on average is
probably going to pass it along to about
two and a half
people on average and so you can do some
math
and you would need about 60 immunity
for the reproduction rate to drop to one
and at a reproduction rate of one that
basically means that the rate of new
cases
would be unchanged so you know if
there's
what 200 000 cases a day now if
everything went back to normal pre
pandemic there would just keep being 200
000 cases a day
you need the reproduction rate to drop
below one before cases start dropping
so like 60 is is right at the cusp
of how many people would need immunity
to you know basically let the thing
peter out
naturally if all restrictions were
dropped
so anyway we gotta pump those numbers up
those are rookie numbers
uh and the the one ray of sunshine is
in july uh the same type of survey found
that
instead of it being about 60 40 60
willing to get the vaccine and 40
percent not
it was about 50 50 in july so things are
trending in a positive direction
um and hopefully they'll continue to do
so but
anyway uh overall pretty positive news i
tried as hard as i could to put a
cynical spin on it but
uh this is all net positive enough that
i can't be that curmudgeonly about it
very very exciting yeah you know one of
the reasons that i didn't
put that in the good news is like i've
tried i've been trying
to adhere to our initial policy
of keeping this show as a pretty
non-coveted show well we said
we said that was the purpose of the
fireside chats right
but i i've still been trying to adhere
to that a little bit the reason being
like
i don't know you turn on a football game
and like every single segment starts in
these days of covid and it's like
you look at the field of like half the
linemen are out and like
i don't know it's nice to have some
places where you're not getting coveted
information you know what i mean
yeah that's fair but uh but no i mean of
course the vaccine is fantastic news so
uh at least it's the good stuff that
we're sharing you know
but it did get to that point especially
like man a couple months into it you
could not
consume a piece of media that was not
fully about covid
i mean if if we want a non-covet related
more
tainted good news story uh on one of
on one of the good news sites i checked
to to try to find good news uh for this
segment of the podcast
apparently the queen of england is
launching a line of gin
uh which is exactly what the [ __ ] the
royal family needs
just another way to generate wealth uh
it's very dark uh the royal family
shouldn't exist
i'm not saying i'm not saying they
should be killed i just think that
that uh monarchy shouldn't be a thing
anymore
fair enough just my opinion interesting
perspective
we'll have to have an episode about
forms of government and which ones we
think are most appropriate
hell yeah um okay i've got some good
news uh
partial good news uh i try to keep in
line with our
general cynical approach to being happy
so listeners of the show know that we've
talked a lot about open science
and this idea of like hey you know
reviewers should be getting paid
they're very skilled people providing a
very important service
for entities that make obscene amounts
of money
so like that's a pretty intuitive
relationship there
the people doing that review ought to be
getting paid well
we've got a partial victory for the open
science movement so
you'll recall a while back we talked
about nature and they were going they
were
developing a new open access route and
for the low cost of about 12 000
you could give them your work for free
and they would own it for twelve
thousand dollars um but there's another
wrinkle there there's kind of another
layer to this kind of
system that they're rolling out for some
of their smaller journals to make it an
even better deal
yes yeah so for some of their smaller
journals not the big highlight
you know the big names um they have this
other system where it's like okay well
we'll review it and uh there will be a
cost up front
like you pay us to get your paper
reviewed
we might reject it and that cost is
non-refundable but we might publish it
and if we do publish it you'll have to
pay the rest
and so the total cost comes down i don't
know five six thousand dollars
uh united states so uh here's here's the
wrinkle so
the win here the good news is that they
have officially
on paper said their review of a
manuscript
is an important valuable thing that
should be paid for
that's a that's a nice because like
we've looked at the books of some like
some publishing companies that like all
the fees that they put in their
financial statements are just like these
ran like
miscellaneous and like publishing costs
it's like yeah i know it's publishing
cost you're a publisher what is the cost
what is this going to so in this
scenario they actually have said
a review is worth money and this is how
much it's worth
and that's a big win the only downside
is that they're not going to pay the
reviewers any of it
so so they're basically saying this is a
service
this is how much it costs we will
provide zero percent of that service
and take one hundred percent of the
revenue generated
and i mean the these aren't like the
nature
flagship journal but all of these nature
journals have
really high rejection rates correct like
they're basically just saying like
yeah what are their rejection rates do
you think probably around 90
let's say 80 let's be charitable uh
so you know they're charging like 2500
usd
give or take for for people to submit to
review
so basically they're making if we assume
an
80 rejection rate uh which again it's
probably quite a bit higher
they're making 10 grand on papers they
reject
before they make another five grand per
one they accept
like they're they're they're probably
making somewhere in the neighborhood of
like 15 grand per paper
yeah which is [ __ ] bonkers and 10 and
10 grand of that is just on rejections
listen to this listen to this idea
though because this is a this is a
completely fair assessment of the
arrangement
they are telling you as an author if you
pay us like 2600
we will let some person tell you why
your work sucks
and that's the entirety of the
relationship
we're not gonna we're not gonna look
into it and determine how how and why
your work sucks we're gonna let
some other person do it and i see you
have this highlighted
uh part of that relationship is they're
actually making
the unpaid reviewers do even more labor
yeah yeah in return for for the authors
they get a review document
which the publisher says includes more
detailed editorial evaluation than
typical
review reports so like they're making
other people do
even more unpaid labor than before to
give even more detailed notes back about
why your paper
sucks uh and they're pocketing like 2
500 usd
off of every single one of them yeah
it's it's crazy
this is officially this has officially
crossed the line for a lot of people
i've seen twitter in a bit of a
a bit of an outrage about it where
people are like i'm not going to review
for these journals anymore
but uh but yeah i don't want to belabor
the point too much because this is for
like
you know a small percentage of the
audience is probably super interested in
these dynamics
no everyone should be interested in it
because for the most part so you think
like
well okay uh like if if it costs this
much and if it's such a bad deal like
the scientists just aren't gonna pay for
it and uh
you know the market's gonna sort it out
but the thing is
uh the scientists aren't the one paying
for it you're the one paying for it
that's a good point because most of
these fees are being covered by grants
from government
agencies so like tax dollars are paying
for it uh
and the thing is like so i forget the
names
the name of the law but like there there
was a law passed uh
like by the eu maybe like two or three
years ago that basically said
anything that gets eu funded has to be
published open access
uh and they as far as i can tell
essentially write a blank check
saying like you know like open access
journals have uh
have publication fees like that's how
they work and so like you know if you
get it published you have to publish it
open access
uh and tax dollars are gonna cover that
like
if you're using public funds public
funds are going to pay
for it to be published open access uh
and
i i'm pretty sure california passed a
similar law
uh in the u.s and i know that that's
already been the case for
uh nih and nsf funded projects for a
while now
yeah uh like they have to be published
open access and like
the grants from those government
agencies are the ones covering the
publication fees
and so if you're an author it makes all
the sense in the world
to submit to a nature journal because
like if it gets accepted
and you have to pay the twelve thousand
dollars you don't have to pay the twelve
thousand dollars the [ __ ]
government's gonna pay the twelve
thousand dollars
uh and if it gets rejected like that's
fine but like if it does get accepted
like that's a very very good line on
your cv
to be published in a nature journal uh
and so like
there's really no disincentive here for
the authors
uh and they're just like
they're spending your money but more
importantly uh [ __ ] springer nature
is taking your money
because they know that there's nothing
stopping them from being able to do that
yeah it's not great okay uh
so that's all the good news i i hope
you've gotten your fill for the week
uh what about some feats of strength uh
yeah so i have
five this week uh gonna start outside of
power lifting uh because i
i think feats of strength basically just
turns into what are strong people in
powerlifting doing
uh so gonna start in strong man mark
jeans
uh i don't know if this actually like
set a new record like in a record book
somewhere i'm not totally sure how
record keeping for
strongman works uh it may have just been
a training lift but he
uh he shouldered the heaviest atlas
stone that a human has ever shouldered
so typically if you're doing atlas
stones uh
you're you're just loading them over a
bar um
ranging from like 40 inches would be
really low
60 inches would be really high but like
somewhere in that general range so
you know if you can get it up to
somewhere around chest level
like that's generally all you have to do
with stones uh
shouldering it as the name implies is
getting it all the way up
to your shoulder which is considerably
harder than just getting it up to your
chest
so he shouldered a 474 pound atlas stone
which is
bonkers that's crazy uh and if you've
never [ __ ] around with stones before
you don't know how crazy that is like
stones are [ __ ] hard dude
uh and that's a shitload of weight to
shoulder
uh so congratulations to mark uh the
previous
the the previous heaviest anyone had
ever shouldered i think was
211 kilos so
what's that like 460 give or take 466.
uh so yeah very very strong very
impressive
uh moving back to my wheelhouse of
powerlifting
uh ashton ruska uh usapl lifter he
recently totaled uh 950 and a half
kilos or 2095 and a half pounds
uh in the 105 kilo or 231
pound weight class that uh
that puts his total 50 kilos ahead uh or
110 pounds ahead of the next closest
person
in that weight class uh i'm pretty sure
he's still a really light 105 as well
he he competed in uh in the 93
kilo class until pretty recently so
he still has a ton of room to grow into
that class uh
and also most of the lifts he did in the
meet
it looked like he had a fair bit more in
the tank definitely on bench
uh for the squad his third attempt squat
looked a little shaky going down but it
still came up fast
uh so i mean he he currently has more in
the tank
and he's still making progress pretty
quickly so
you know dominating that class right now
and there is
no reason to expect he won't continue to
do so in the future
moving on uh to the less drug-tested
side of powerlifting
yuri belkin uh deadlifted 445 kilos or
981 pounds
uh as a very light 242 or
110 kilo lifter he weighed in at 227
or 103 he kind of bounces back and forth
between the 100 and 110 classes
and he recently lost his deadlift record
to jamal browner
so he said okay i'm going to put on two
pounds and take it back
uh so very very strong very crazy
uh there's gonna be it looks like
multiple
uh 110 kilo lifters deadlifting in the
thousands
soon uh so that's bad [ __ ] crazy
but very very cool um
christy hawkins moving on uh so she
currently has the deadlift world record
in the untested female
165 pound or 75 kilo weight class
at 262 and a half kilos or 578 pounds
she recently pulled 275 kilos or 606
in training so it looks like she is
going to be the first
middleweight female lifter to break a
600 pound deadlift in a meet
which is also just absolutely bonkers
so congrats to her and finally
probably the most freakish of all of
them uh eddie berglund
he is a swedish ipf lifter
recently moved from the junior class to
the open
uh he did a training meet like a mock
meet
uh and he hit uh
a 730 kilo total which would break the
record
by 24.5 kilos or 54 pounds
uh which is you know that's impressive
enough on its own
but the the very freakish part of this
is the lift breakdown so
so it eddie berglund is probably like
the dude people have in mind if they
think
folks with really extreme bench arches
and like hyper efficient bench technique
uh so he's uh
he has one of the most impressive bench
techniques in powerlifting like
i don't think it's bad or cheating i
think it's [ __ ] awesome
uh but yeah if it's within the rules it
is not cheating yeah he has like a two
inch range of motion and like
if i could have a two inch range of
motion i would yeah and if like any
competitive power lifter could they
would
like whatever people can get mad they
can [ __ ] die mad
i don't care but anyway uh hyper
efficient bench press technique and that
allows him
to hit a gym total of uh
250 235 245
or in freedom units that's a 551 pound
squat
518 pound bench and 540 pound deadlift
which like that's crazy dude uh
i don't i mean i i would i would need to
check
uh the archives but if he were to put
that up in a meet
uh and break the world record i don't
know if there's ever been a world record
total
where the bench is that high of a
percentage of it
uh just absolutely wild [ __ ] that would
break
the bench record in his weight class as
well oh
also keep in mind uh he's he's a 66 kilo
lifter or 145 pounds
a 518 bench at 145
that's wild like that's absolutely crazy
uh
and that would break the bench record by
uh 12 and a half kilos
in his weight class or 27 and a half
pounds
so you know he he's
up there in in the great white north
just absolutely thriving
uh pressing his bench presses exactly
an inch and a half and you know making
people on instagram
mad uh so props to the guy more power to
him
absolutely all right that's good stuff a
lot of a lot of really good feats of
strength
uh so we're gonna move on and talk about
research basically the rest of the show
is gonna be a nice
long research roundup uh
hitting the highlights so it's it's not
like a research review segment where we
do 40 minutes on a single study but
we're going to hit the highlights
because there's been
a lot of cool research that's come out
lately and greg every month you write
three articles from ask
i write two and there's only so many we
can hit
on a month-to-month basis you know we do
our journal sweep which is i mean we
usually get what three or four hundred
studies per month
yeah thereabouts uh which is publicly
available by the way if you wanna
read three or four hundred of the most
notable studies each month
uh it's there but uh but we wanna go
through some of the highlights
and the first one i want to begin with
is a meta-analysis about protein intake
and so the lead author's name is tagawa
and uh this came out just last month i
believe
and so you might be thinking well we
already have that
meta by morton and colleagues from 2018
that was looking at basically
you know it used like meta regression
and said how high should our protein be
if we're interested in maximizing our
lean mass gains
over time uh but you know this
meta-analysis is is a little bit
different from that
from that morton one so the morton one i
think a lot of people
kind of forget this but if memory serves
it was specifically the main
point of the paper was about protein
supplementation correct
so it was specifically looking at papers
that included protein
supplements not just studies that look
at
varying in intakes of protein from whole
foods
so um this particular meta-analysis by
tagawa
and colleagues was not just looking at
protein supplementation study so as a
result to that
there was a much larger number of
studies included in this analysis so
in the morton study or meta-analysis
they looked at that meta-regression that
classic figure that you see posted all
over the place
i use it in some of my talks as well but
it had 42 study arms with two
sorry it was 723 total participants
well in this meta in the analysis where
they were looking at kind of optimizing
protein intakes
it included data from 105 articles and a
total of
over 5 400 participants uh
and about 2700 of those 5400 were doing
resistance training
as part of their their protein
intervention
so basically what they did the real uh
if you just wanted to get a pretty basic
assessment of this meta analysis a lot
like the morton study
there's kind of this one figure that
really jumps out that kind of summarizes
the findings in general
and what they did is they had a grid it
was a three by three grid with nine
different graphs
within this figure and the reason they
did that
is you know they had basically an
unadjusted
raw model with no covariates and then
they had
two other models with different
groupings of covariates included
they're trying to be really thorough and
say you know we talked about this in the
past
sometimes studies will just give you a
model with a bunch of covariates and
you kind of have to hope that the
covariates make sense and you can't
really determine how much they impacted
the model if they don't include the raw
model as well so this was great they had
the raw model
an adjusted model and then another
adjusted model and they also presented
it
each of those models in three different
ways so they looked at all of the
studies together
and then they looked at the studies with
people doing resistance training
and then the studies with people who
weren't doing resistance training to see
if there would be a difference
now the the real conclusion of this
study um
you know they have these nine different
graphs uh and they
of course have some differences from
from panel to panel
but generally speaking they are pretty
consistent
and what they find is the following
there is an inflection point
so there's a steep part of the graph and
then a less steep
so the steep part basically indicates
that
as your protein intake your daily
protein intake
increases from zero to about
1.3 1.5 grams per kilogram of body mass
per day
there's a pretty steep slope you know as
you keep increasing your protein up to
that point you're getting
pretty notable improvements in your lean
body mass gains
over the course of an intervention and
frankly with or without lifting
uh just because the the results line up
pretty well with both
the main difference here is that you
know they have that kind of
flatter part of the figure where it's
like okay
once you get above 1.3 1.5 ish
grams per kilogram per day the
relationship flattens out so it's not
like a
small increase in protein is going to
have a huge impact
on your lean mass improvements but one
of the big differences here of course
there's a subtle difference comparing
this to the morton results which is
instead of the line being at 1.6 it's
closer to the 1.3 1.5 range depending on
which
particular part of the figure the the
break point the break point yeah
yeah what did i say you said the line
yeah yeah the the break point in the
line
is uh is a little bit but i mean that's
functionally the same thing right
yeah if we're talking about oh it's 1.4
or 1.6 it
it's pretty much the same thing the big
difference is that
in these figures that
less steep part after the inflection
point where the where the
the line kind of flattens out the big
difference in
in these results compared to morton is
these don't totally flatten out
so in the morton figure from that 2018
paper it's like it
increased up to 1.6 and was flat like
extremely flat was wasn't that part of
their model specification like
they basically went in a priori
saying like past a certain point
additional protein intake
will not have uh will not have an effect
and therefore we're looking for the
point where it goes flat
like i'm pretty sure that's what they
did yeah i'd have to
double check that in the methods but
that sounds realistic because it's flat
as hell
yeah when you look at the figure with
these particular models it's not flat
and so you still get some degree of
benefit in these models from increasing
your protein
up to 1.8 2.0 2.2 and so on
you still get some benefit but it's just
not as notable as
when you're way further down the curve
when you're down
increasing from one gram per kilogram to
1.5
much larger difference than if you're
increasing it from 2.1 to 2.6
so functionally these results line up
pretty well
with the morton results and and
basically
it's nice to see another study
indicating that we have a pretty good
idea at where we start to kind of
uh max out our benefits of higher
protein diets
more or less like there's still benefits
beyond that point but
knowing where that inflection point is
is really helpful for setting practical
guidelines of
how much protein should i get in um to
make sure that i'm doing my best without
displacing other important nutrients you
know
so what they conclude though so if you
just like
kind of jump into the abstract what they
indicate is
uh you know the way they put it is that
slightly increasing
protein intake uh enhances lean mass
gains in a dose-dependent manner
in a range going from 0.5 to 3.5 grams
per kilogram per day
and so without looking at the figures
you might be inclined to think oh damn
i've been eating 1.8
i should bump it to 3.5 because like
dose response i know what that
means and i want the biggest response so
i'm going to up the dose
um but looking at the models the dose
lift the most
exactly yeah a different interpretation
of upping the dose
but when you look at the models you
basically get the same idea which is
that
you definitely want to be up into that
1.4
1.6 1.8 range if you want to make sure
you're getting the most bang for your
buck with protein
how far you go beyond that depends on
like i said
at what point are we unnecessarily
displacing other nutrients in the diet
and so that usually is what's your
functional limiter
of how high we push that or just satiety
if you're just like dude i can't keep
eating
300 grams of protein per day so um
it's one of those studies that i wanted
to bring it up because first of all it
kind of reinforces
a lot of the practical application that
a lot of people are already advocating
so this doesn't like change our our idea
of protein intake and flip it on its
head
but i also wanted to kind of clarify a
little nuance behind that abstract
because
if you just look at the abstract you'd
probably be inclined to think like damn
dude
i've only been eating 1.9 i need to like
double it you know which is
probably not the case yeah yeah uh
just add even more context the up the
dose lift the most
uh quip so this is
i'm not gonna use names uh i don't
want i don't want people starting social
media drama with me don't have time for
that in my life
uh so i'll leave this anonymous but it's
one of the more
incredible things i've seen in lifting
culture on the internet
uh and i want to share it with you dear
listener
so uh there was a very well known
very not drug free lifter uh
posting about training and uh someone
in the comments said like hey uh so and
so
uh i'm 15 i'm just getting into
powerlifting
you're my idol i want to be just like
you like
what what tips do you have for me to
become
the next you uh and this person
huge platform very well known
interacting with a teenager
probably you know maybe two years into
puberty at most
responds up the dose lift the most wall
that was just that was his which
like to be fair uh that very well
probably is uh a non-negligible amount
of
uh of this guy's success so like it's
good that he has the wherewithal to
realize that but like
not great that he didn't have the
wherewithal to to tell a 15 year old kid
like dude just do drugs
yeah it's uh
he is he's the fictitious character they
warned us about in the dare lessons
you know that for these ultra cool
people are gonna
you know offer you drugs your entire
life and tell you that you have to take
them to be cool like them
yeah yeah apparently okay i apologize to
dare
i guess they they had a point oh man
all right so uh yeah let's move on
and keep talking about protein a little
bit um
so there was a
i guess i can call it a meta study it's
an it's an analysis
of four studies from a particular lab
group
the title is essential amino acids and
protein synthesis
colon insights into maximizing the
muscle and whole body response to
feeding
by church and colleagues and so
basically what they did
is they compiled data from four studies
out of their lab
looking at changes in both muscle
protein synthesis
and whole body protein synthesis
following protein feedings with
different levels
of essential amino acid concentrations
uh and and they basically wanted to see
um just kind of like what
essential amino acid related variables
would be related to muscle
protein synthesis or if they would be in
the first place
um and so they looked
uh at changes in muscle protein
synthesis and whole body
uh protein synthesis associated with the
area under the curve
for essential amino acids in the blood
for
essential amino acid maximum
concentration in the blood
changes in an essential amino acid
concentration after feeding
and the rate of increase of essential
amino acid concentration
and they basically found that all four
of those things were
significantly positively associated with
muscle protein synthesis so if you have
a greater area under the curve
muscle protein synthesis is going to
ramp up to a greater degree
if you had a higher maximum essential
amino acid concentration
muscle protein synthesis is going to
ramp up to a greater degree
etc the r values for those associations
range from about
0.42 to about 7.24
and the for muscle protein synthesis
specifically
the strongest association was for
maximum
essential amino acid concentration in
the blood that you hit
after a protein feeding one thing that's
notable is
this this finding was basically
independent of total protein intake
so these studies looked at a lot of
different
protein containing foods ranging from
like whey protein by itself whey protein
spiked with
various levels of essential amino acids
uh
eggs meat nuts
i believe beans like a whole bunch of
different things and they found that
independent of of total protein intake
all of these various essential amino
acid related variables were
associated with muscle protein synthesis
so like i said they were primarily
looking at four studies out of their lab
group
but they also brought in 13 other
studies in the literature that
basically looked at at the same sorts of
things
so you know varying levels of essential
amino acid intakes and then
postprandial uh changes in muscle
protein
synthesis and the the group mean
findings of those 13 studies tracked
really really well with the regression
lines from the individual subject data
from the four studies they were looking
at
um so this is uh
this constitutes a pretty strong result
suggesting that
you know not the only thing that matters
for uh for muscle protein synthesis
being essential amino acid intake but
that it's
a very very uh important thing
the reason that this stuck in my mind
when i saw it is
um i i saw bill campbell post
on instagram maybe two weeks ago about
uh muscle protein synthesis following
bcaa
intake uh and like i don't really follow
amino acid research that closely uh
i don't know like i follow lifting
research more
and so like i kind of had in my mind
that like
you know both essential amino acids and
branched chain amino acids
as things that one might consume are
both
probably inferior to whole proteins and
like maybe essential amino acids are a
little better but like
you know they're probably not all that
much different uh
because like leucine seems to be the
really important trigger and if you're
taking a branched chain
supplement or an essential amino acid
supplement you're gonna have a fair
amount of leucine in it either way
uh but uh bill's post on instagram which
i
dug up the resources for and checked for
accuracy and of course
bill's legit it was accurate uh
apparently only like
of the studies that look at muscle
protein synthesis
after specific like branch chain amino
acid specific supplementation
two of them found uh increases in muscle
protein synthesis
two found no meaningful change and two
actually found
uh decreases in muscle protein synthesis
so
it really seems like branched chain
amino acids by themselves don't really
do that much for you whereas
essential amino acids uh do seem to come
in pretty clutch
and be pretty predictive of of uh
postprandial
uh mps so anyway uh
yeah i guess i'm i'm pretty strongly in
the essential amino acid camp uh if if
that
battle were being held so i i think in
general
if you're mostly getting your protein
from animal sources it's going to have
a fair amount of all of the essential
amino acids
anyways but i think the study does
suggest
that if you're maybe a vegan or if
you're a vegetarian who just doesn't
consume
that many eggs or that many dairy
products it might actually not be a
terrible idea
to get an essential amino acid
supplementation and just take a little
bit along with your meals
uh because it does seem like they they
really
are uh collectively not just leucine
in isolation uh do seem to be a pretty
big driving factor
for uh postprandial muscle protein
synthesis
yeah i mean you know that's kind of the
what i've always advocated not always i
mean when i was like
seven or eight years old i didn't even
care to be honest but
in recent years you know branch chain
amino acids got pretty big they got
pretty popular
and then people were like wait a minute
shouldn't we be having like
other essential amino acids too and the
answer is yeah
like you definitely should so like
maybe if you were if you were eating
some particular combination of foods
where
you had all of your amino acid bases
covered
except for the branched chain amino
acids if you were in that rare scenario
it might make sense but generally
speaking you're going to be far better
off with an essential
amino acid supplement for sure
okay moving on i've got a couple studies
here about meal timing
and uh i honestly i'll be transparent i
just included these because i thought it
was funny
um there's a point to be made though
so like sometimes you'll talk to people
who are
they kind of are loosely connected
they'll look at the news headlines
about health research or nutrition
research
and they'll like hold on to it and
eventually it leads to frustration right
you'll talk to people who aren't super
in touch with with the up-to-date
research and they're like dude
they told me this was bad six months ago
now they're saying it's good in six
months they're gonna say it's bad again
like
the mixed messaging and the headlines is
just annoying so i'm just gonna
stop caring about all of it you know
what i mean it can cause a lot of
fatigue and frustration when there's
contradictory
takeaway points uh you know from the
headline
so there are three studies that came out
within the last like month
that looked at meal timing in different
ways
and this is the important thing i'm not
saying that any one of these three
studies was done
poorly it's three studies looking at the
same thing from a different perspective
with a different research design
with a slightly different research
question even
and so the first one is called late
eating is associated with cardio
metabolic risk traits obesogenic
behaviors
and impaired weight loss the second one
is called higher eating frequency is
associated with lower adiposity and
robust circadian rhythms
a cross-sectional study and the third is
called impact of meal
frequency on anthropometric outcomes a
systematic review
and network meta-analysis of randomized
controlled trials
and so if you were a person who was just
like okay i'm going to skim these and
get the headlines
the first peop the first paper basically
concludes grading eat a greater eating
frequency
greater than five eating occasions per
day greater than five meals per day
was significantly associated with a
lower bmi
easy eat more meals lower bmi
good stuff stoke that metabolic furnace
baby exactly
simple stuff now the next one
says our results suggest that late
eating is associated with
cardiometabolic risk factors
and reduced efficacy of a weight loss
intervention so
that makes it a little tricky because
it's like we'll eat plenty of meals
but none of them late in the evening so
it's like well that naturally is going
to kind of truncate the number of meals
you can eat if you have to kind of
squeeze them all earlier in the day
they're not necessarily directly
contradictory but you're already getting
a little bit of mixed messages like
should i spread this stuff over several
meals throughout the day
or should i not now here's where the
message gets
even more mixed so this is from the
third study i believe
it said one meal per day was ranked as
the best eating frequency for reduced
body weight followed by two meals per
day
our suggest our results suggest that two
meals per day
probably slightly reduces body weight
compared to three meals per day
but we are uncertain if one or two meals
per day reduces body weight compared
with
greater than or equal to eight meals per
day
and so the take home there is
you know the first two studies said you
know eat more meals
but none of them late or eat
as few as possible unless you're gonna
eat eight or more
so like have one or two or nine
and so like if someone was was keeping
up with these this month they'd be like
dude
what the hell am i supposed to do with
this you know and the important thing to
take away from this is like
the headlines are gonna make it seem
very clear and concise and simple
but you really have to dig into okay
what exact research question were they
looking at
how exactly were they assessing it and
what you'll find is that multiple groups
can look at the same question
with slightly different perspectives and
with slightly different research
approaches
and we we end up with these convoluted
and completely contradictory conclusions
when we try to put them all together
into a tidy story so it's i just thought
it was kind of funny because
i taught a an undergraduate class about
research interpretation
and we would look at study headlines and
then look at the study itself and say oh
well
the headline seem stupid but there's
actually some
there's these are not stupid people
doing the research right like
the research itself was fine but we
played a little bit of telephone things
got mixed up
and it's just always really critical
whenever you run into those
contradictory headlines like
take a look at at least the abstract to
get an idea of like oh
okay these are very different studies
when you really get down into the
details
but of course i want to give something
that's useful here i think
from my perspective one of the big uh
issues when you look at the meal
frequency literature
is that a lot of the research adopts one
of two perspectives
some studies are looking at it from more
of a
public health basic guideline
perspective so like
you probably heard one of the studies
specifically looked at obesogenic
traits it was more focused on like what
cluster of behaviors
seems to be associated with whether or
not you eat at night
or eat really frequently throughout the
day so this is like
from a you know very far back
perspective
just taking a look at like okay we got
some people who don't eat
a lot of meals some people who do eat a
lot of meals who seems to be having
success here you know
that's a very different perspective from
looking at a very controlled
individual level intervention and saying
like if we give this person a meal
three hours later than we did in the
other group is it going to completely
harpoon their success
like those are very very different
perspectives when you look at this
research and
i think danny lennon did a really nice
job looking at the
the perspective that i find a little bit
more informative for what i do
like i don't make public health
guidelines i
help people reach their physique goals
right or their performance goals
and so what i want to know is at the
individual level is there a meal timing
strategy that necessarily
is going to completely destroy your
progress or really hinder your ability
to approach your goals
what we know based on the the controlled
interventions
you can honestly succeed with whatever
the hell kind of meal frequency you want
i think it makes sense to have at least
three protein servings per day i usually
recommend three to five
within that framework you can do
whatever the hell you want i mean we've
got really good interventions that we've
talked about on the show
where people are doing time restricted
feeding eight hour feeding window
uh as long as you're not trying to
maximize hypertrophy
you can even go a hell of a lot shorter
than eight than eight hours like
i've there's really no meal frequency
strategy that is
completely off the table but i think if
you really wanted to optimize it
based on kind of the most current
evidence we have i think danny did a
great job
in his uh article about chrono nutrition
is it chrono or chrono nutrition
i've always said chrono chrono nutrition
that sounds good
um but basically if you really wanted to
optimize things and kind of hedge your
bets and say
i want to really sweat over the details
of this
avoiding meals during biological night
so during the time period where you
typically sleep
each day it's probably a good idea to
avoid nighttime meals
um you want to probably not eat within
two to three hours of sleep time
generally bias more of your calories
earlier in the day
have consistent meal times from day to
day so getting in a meal timing rhythm
uh whatever you're doing keeping it
pretty consistent
probably makes sense to have some type
of restricted feeding window
which doesn't mean you know snake diet
like eat once every four days
but basically have a period of the day
what you know maybe it's like
12 hours or something where even if it's
only
ten eight hours but a period of the day
where you're not eating where you have
some kind of like overnight fast
and what danny says is start with a 12
hour fasting period which is just a
that's just a normal eating schedule
right eating for 12 hours a day and then
not eating for the other 12
but having some kind of start and stop
time for your meals
and then uh you know the idea of chrono
nutrition is kind of blending nutrition
guidelines
with uh circadian rhythm biology
and so it's always a good idea if you
can get daylight exposure early in the
day
and avoid artificial light especially
blue wavelength light
really late at night so basic basic
instructions
from danny and the article is really
nice he goes into detail about what the
evidence is behind all of those
recommendations but
if you really wanted to stress over the
details and
optimize your eating in order to kind of
you know get your
circadian biology in order those are
maybe
you know the that's probably the most
straightforward set of guidelines that
you could try to aim for
but realistically when you see these
three different studies with three
different
takeaways regarding meal frequency at
the end of the day
we know from the interventions you can
eat whatever the hell you want it's
gonna be fine
i think it's a good idea to get three
big servings of protein at least
throughout the day everything beyond
that is is getting into the
the kind of nitty-gritty details that
probably don't make a huge difference
makes sense to me now i'm really excited
about this next one
uh so this is a paper that a lot of
people have been talking about
uh uncritically just kind of like hey
i mean i see what the conclusion says
makes sense to me feels good
i'm interested to hear your take about
it so take take it away from there
yeah so the the title of the paper is is
stronger better
question mark influence of a strength
phase followed by
a hypertrophy phase on muscular
adaptations in resistance trained men
by carvalho and colleagues
[Music]
noteworthy that is different from
barbalio who we've
talked about on the podcast before
different people it does rhyme though
it does you'll concede that point that
is uh correct
uh anyway so i think this study got
talked about a lot uh in our space
because
most people are either like power
lifters or if they're
physique folks they still want to be
like kind of strong like there there's
there there's a pretty decent i i would
say like
powerlifting centric bias within the
like quote-unquote evidence-based
fitness community uh and so i think
people liked this study because it
confirmed something they wanted to be
true
uh and that's basically the idea that if
you
do a specific strength phase and try to
to maximize strength adaptations that
will then
subsequently improve your hypertrophy
results
in a subsequent hypertrophy phase like
basically
if your muscles get stronger you can
then expose them to greater stress
uh disrupt homeostasis more uh get some
more hypertrophic adaptations and and
that's all gonna be good
uh and so i think like a lot of people
want that to be true
uh and so they saw this paper uh and
that
that's more or less what the findings of
this paper were and they're like ha
yes now we have it we have the golden
study
that backs up this thing that we've been
suggesting to be true all these years
and now we know it to be true
um and anyway i'm somewhat skeptical of
that take
as someone who definitely wants this to
be true
but anyway let's get into it so in this
study uh the subjects were trained men
um they averaged i think about four
years of training experience and all
squatted at least one and a half times
body mass
so you know they're not gonna
uh like do anything crazy on a
powerlifting platform but like
reasonably strong for folks
uh in the resistance training literature
and so to start the study um they they
split the subjects into two groups
uh one group was to do just like a pure
hypertrophy training program
the other group was to start with
strength training and then do
hypertrophy training
but both groups started with a
standardized three-week lead-in phase
so for three weeks before the the group
started training differently
they had three weeks where they trained
twice per week uh doing
squats and leg press for four sets uh
with
eight to twelve rep max loads twice per
week uh did that for three weeks
then they did their pre-training testing
and then the
the training programs of the groups
differed so there was a group that only
did hypertrophy training for eight weeks
uh so they kept doing four sets of eight
to twelve rm squats and leg presses
twice per week
for all eight weeks and then the other
group
did a three week strength phase where
they still did squats and leg presses
twice per week but instead of
sets of eight to 12 rep max they did
four sets with a one to three rep max
load
twice per week for three weeks and then
for the last five weeks of the study
they did the same program as the other
group so four sets with an 8 to 12 rep
max load
for the last five weeks of the study so
they assessed one rep max squat and leg
press strength and vastus lateralis
thickness
after the lead-in after uh three weeks
of the differentiated training
intervention so after the the strength
of the hypertrophy group had finished
their strength phase
and then after all eight weeks of the
training program were concluded
during the first three weeks the group
who started with their strength phase
gained more strength so they put about
16
kilos on their squat compared to four
for the hypertrophy group
about 29 kilos on their leg press
compared to 10 for the hypertrophy group
but there wasn't much hypertrophy in
either group
but the non-significant difference
did lean in favor of the group doing the
hypertrophy program so
they increased their vastus lateralis
thickness by about 0.6 millimeters
compared to about 0.2 millimeters
in the group starting with the strength
phase one thing to note is
all of those changes i just listed
including a mere
4 kilo increase on the squat and a mere
0.2 millimeter increase of vastus
lateralis thickness
all of those within group changes were
statistically significant
come back to that later then from weeks
four to eight so the last five weeks of
the study there were
comparable strength gains between groups
during that period
but there was more hypertrophy in the
group that had previously done a
strength phase
so their vastus lateralis thickness
increased by about 1.2 millimeters
compared to about 0.4 millimeters in the
group that was only doing
hypertrophy training so over the entire
course of the study from week 0 to week
8
there were significantly greater
strength gains
and significantly more hypertrophy in
the group
that did the 3 week strength phase at
the start of the study compared to the
group that just did hypertrophy training
for the entire
eight week intervention so
you know that that seems pretty
conclusive you know
start with three weeks of strength work
followed by
five weeks of hypertrophy training and
that's gonna
not only help you build more strength
than just doing eight weeks of
hypertrophy training
it'll help you build more muscle as well
and that sounds great
and that is about all of the discussion
i've seen of it just like hey
these were the findings uh this is there
for the truth
and uh let's roll baby you want to get
big
it's time to do some heavy doubles heavy
triples um
so you know this begs the question are
physique athletes shooting themselves in
the foot by
never doing maximal strength work or
only very rarely
doing maximal strength work uh
you know is getting stronger primarily
via
kind of neural mechanisms beneficial for
hypertrophy is
is power building the way of the future
uh and so i'm skeptical and i'm
skeptical for
a couple reasons first this finding
conflicts with other research so it
uh somewhat directly conflicts with the
study by presti's and colleagues in 2009
so in that study they compared linear
periodization to
reverse linear periodization so
basically
starting lighter and working heavier
versus
starting heavier and working lighter and
they found
that linear periodization led to both
greater strength gains
and larger accumulations of fat-free
mass which
they didn't directly assess hypertrophy
but that was their
hypertrophy proxy in that study whereas
this study would suggest that
you would expect a reverse linear to be
better so start with heavy loads and
then do
more like pure hypertrophy training
later on in the program so
these findings do conflict with presti's
and colleagues
uh but you know you can't necessarily
say like oh the the first study in an
area is necessarily the correct one
but it's also worth noting this kind of
indirectly conflicts with
uh the research comparing high load and
low load training so
in basically all of those studies groups
doing heavier training
so you know 75 80 1rm
they build more strength but similar
amounts of muscle to
groups training uh with anything from
like a 20
rep max load all the way down to like 30
of one rm which
is like a 40 or 50 rep max load uh so
you see
pretty big differences in strength gains
uh
and you know presumably those
differences in strength accumulation
start occurring relatively early in the
program similar to this study
so you know you see big differences in
strength accumulation typically but
not meaningful differences in
hypertrophy
uh this isn't in the outline but
something else that just occurred to me
is like this
also somewhat conflicts with uh the
research comparing
uh the effects of different
periodization styles
on uh hypertrophy so there's
there's not a significant difference
between linear periodization and
undulating periodization and
most of the undulating periodization
work uses
uh daily undulating periodization so
basically with with dup
you're going heavy uh at least once a
week
throughout so you're getting that heavy
you're getting exposed to heavy loading
uh early and all throughout an entire
training program versus
linear periodization way it's mostly set
up in the literature is you don't really
touch fairly heavy weights until like
the last three or four weeks before
testing
so basically you know one would then
expect
um like dup to be superior for
hypertrophy
and again that's not what you see in the
literature so this
this finding you know does does conflict
directly with
one study and indirectly with two entire
bodies of literature so
you know that in and of itself is is
worth some skepticism i would say
um to push back against that uh
one alternative possibility that might
explain the findings of this study
is that there might just be some some
degree of benefit for
adding variety in so in a recent podcast
episode
we talked about how you know maybe you
can
quote unquote resensitize yourself to a
hypertrophy stimulus
and the thing to note about this study
is both of the groups had a
lead-in period that lasted three weeks
where the training was identical to the
hypertrophy training that the
hypertrophy group did like throughout
the entire
eight-week intervention so basically
the the strength then hypertrophy group
did three weeks of hypertrophy training
three weeks of strength training
five weeks of hypertrophy training and
the hypertrophy group
basically just did 11 weeks straight of
hypertrophy training so it may not
necessarily be that the
strength phase matters insofar as it's a
strength phase
it may just be that like you know 11
weeks of a hypertrophy stimulus
you might kind of like burn out to it i
guess like
you know not burn out but it it just
becomes progressively less effective
over time
uh and if you just like you know slot a
few weeks in where you do something
different that helps you re-sensitize to
the synth
to the stimulus i don't know if that's
what's taking place but that is
uh an alternative hypothesis for what
was observed in the study that wouldn't
necessarily conflict
uh with the other research we have um so
you know that's one possibility um but i
have
other reasons to be skeptical of this
particular research finding
beyond just the fact that it does
conflict with some other research
um so there were some uh like
weird statistical and data issues in
this study
so uh one thing that i that i mentioned
before said i'd come back to later
is the changes in basically every
measure of this study were
remarkably homogeneous so uh one of the
things i mentioned
is all of the changes in this study were
were remarkably homogeneous so in the
group that did the strength phase first
followed by the hypertrophy phase during
that first three weeks when they were
doing
their strength phase their vastus
lateralis thickness
increased from 22.6 to 22.8 millimeters
that is a change of 0.2 millimeters not
two millimeters
dude yeah two tenths of a millimeter
when i was looking at the outline
my brain registered that as two
millimeters just by default because i
can't think of a thing smaller than a
millimeter no no
half of a millimeter or 0.2 of a
millimeter yeah a
fifth of a millimeter uh but the
within-group changes were homogeneous
enough
for that to be a statistically
significant within group change uh
i am unaware of any other study
with with homogeneous enough hypertrophy
responses
for a 0.2 millimeter change in muscle
thickness
to be significant when you're dealing
with a group sample size of 15 subjects
that's remarkably homogenate
a remarkable amount of homogeneity uh
and the same thing applies to a lesser
degree with the
four kilo increase in squat strength in
the hypertrophy group in the first three
weeks
generally if you're dealing with an
increase in strength that small
again with with relatively small group
sizes that's not going to be a
significant change
and if it is it's it's very very
homogeneous so that's
um you know just something that jumped
out at me
uh another thing that jumped out at me
um
which i may be telling on myself a
little bit here
[ __ ] like this jumps out at me i don't
think it jumps out at anyone else
but there were several issues with
confidence intervals and p-values not
matching up
so basically a confidence interval
implies a p-value so if you know the
confidence interval you can
calculate the p-value and if you know
the p-value you can calculate the
confidence interval if one is given but
not the other
and basically the way that works is if
you're using
the traditional null hypothesis testing
cutoff of a p-value
under 0.05 being significant if you have
a p-value that's
just barely under 0.05 the bottom end of
a 95
confidence interval is supposed to be
scraping zero
it's supposed to be very very close so
the entire confidence interval is
contained
within like either to the left or to the
right of zero
it doesn't cross zero but it gets super
super close
if there's a p value that's super close
to 0.05
and so for the between group comparison
of percentage change in vastus lateralis
thickness
the reported p-value is 0.049
barely below 0.05 in favor of the group
that did the strength phase first
followed by hypertrophy
but the 95 confidence interval is 0.15
to 3.2 percent
uh difference like the that's the
between group difference
and you can you can do the math like you
can just google the equation that you
can
you can punch the numbers into uh but
basically that implies
a p-value of 0.031
which that may not sound like a big
difference but like that's
definitely more than a rounding error um
and so like that jumped out at me like p
value
or p values and confidence intervals
should match up like if you're using a
standard statistical software and it
spits out your p-values and confidence
intervals
they should match up uh and if if
they're not
like something strange is going on
it's like looking at results from body
composition testing and it's like
we've got all of our fat free mass and
our fat mass and it's
noticeably different from your total
mass right you look at it you're like
that small p-value difference might not
seem consequential but it's still just
like puzzle
pieces that don't fit together yeah or
if you have like a standard deviation
and standard error that don't match up
right like a standard error is your
standard deviation divided by the square
root of
your sample size and so if you have nine
subjects per group
and your standard error is not one-third
of your standard deviation
something weird happened right it's
supposed to be exactly one-third of your
standard deviation
not necessarily something nefarious but
something weird right
yeah yeah like some something odd
happened
uh so anyway that jumped out at me and
and that wasn't the only
instance of that happening that's just
the one i'm using for this example
uh and finally uh
one thing that that i have to give
people props
for the university where this took place
they have
an open data policy so uh we were able
to
get our hands on the data set um and you
know just basically poke around like see
what things look like
and one of the things that jumped out at
me is uh
there wasn't really any meaningful
correlation
between fastest lateralis thickness and
strength
within any of the groups at any of the
time points
so the those correlation coefficients
ranged from
uh negative 0.1 to about 0.4
which are remarkably low for this type
of thing so
if you're looking at like not not the
correlation between
strength gains and hypertrophy but just
kind of baseline
how big are your muscles versus how
strong are you so like cross-sectional
vers
versus longitudinal if you look at the
cross-sectional relationship between
muscle size and strength
in untrained populations you tend to see
a correlation coefficient
somewhere in the neighborhood of about
an r value of like 0.7
give or take and for trained populations
you tend to see
correlations uh from like 0.8 to 0.9
plus
like generally and so like these were
trained lifters you would expect a
pretty strong correlation between vastus
lateralis thickness and both squat and
leg press strength
and that just didn't exist in this study
which again doesn't mean anyone did
anything wrong but it's
uh it's very atypical and so
long story short i personally wouldn't
cite this study as conclusively
demonstrating that people with
hypertrophy goals
should do periods of near-max training
to improve growth
both because it's the first study with
these findings which do
contradict quite a bit of other
literature and because there were some
again like weird data issues that don't
quite sit right with me
and to be clear i'm not alleging any
wrongdoing like i'm not
saying anyone like did anything fishy uh
because
sometimes data are weird purely by
chance
but like the the whole thing with
science is we're we're interested in
generalizability
right so we uh we gather a sample of
people
we put them through something that
should be representative of
of the sort of stimulus that we think
people might impose in the real world
and then we generalize the results from
our sample to
our target population which in this case
is lifters
and the less
representative the sample is of the
target population you want to generalize
to
the iffier it becomes to generalize and
so
i i basically think that the data are
weird enough
that it makes me think that this
population was maybe just like
fundamentally different in some way from
like
typical day-to-day lifters which to me
like
just a priori makes me think that these
data are
are a bit less generalizable uh so
anyway between the weird data and just
the fact that
these findings do uh seem to directly
contradict
another study and indirectly contradict
uh
two two different entire bodies of
literature
um you know i'm not saying that the
results
reported aren't results that actually
happened but
i would want to see at least one
and ideally multiple replications before
i personally would want to put much
stock in the idea
that to maximize hypertrophy you need to
do
occasional super low rep max strength
blocks
that makes sense good stuff and you know
it it's
one of those it doesn't necessarily mean
that you shouldn't do it in practice it
doesn't mean that
that there can't be something there it's
just when when you're evaluating
evidence you know
throwing that link around is not like
the end of the conversation like
i have definitive conclusive proof that
cannot be argued against
correct yeah um all right moving on i've
got an interesting study here
uh this is something that i think the
conclusion isn't gonna be surprising but
i still think the numbers are pretty
pretty remarkable uh we've talked about
sleep quite a bit on the podcast for
good reason i know i do it most nights
you do it generally fewer nights than i
do but
it's important uh sleep has been tied to
everything good basically like feeling
good
cognitively and physically performing
well it's strongly associated with not
feeling sleepy
correct absolutely so sleep
is important uh people that sleep well
do
have better results in training programs
they have better results with diets it's
just a good thing to get adequate sleep
so this study the title was
caloric and macronutrient intake and
meal timing responses to repeated sleep
restriction exposures
separated by varying intervening
recovery nights
in healthy adults so the idea was
um they had 35 participants
uh who did this study and there were two
baseline nights where they got an idea
of kind of just their general
uh food consumption habits when they're
sleeping plenty so
these two baseline nights they spent 10
hours in bed
and then that was followed by a few
different
uh types of sleep restriction
intervention so
on a sleep restricted night they were
only spending
four hours in bed uh so not necessarily
four hours of sleep
versus ten hours of sleep but four hours
in bed versus ten hours in bed
and i would i would assume so these uh
sleep restriction periods were five
nights in a row
i bet by the end of that four hours in
bed is
probably 3.99 hours of sleep
like the second i know for me the second
i hit the pillow i'd probably be
completely out oh yeah but um anyway so
they they had these two different five
day periods where for those five days
straight they were only spending four
hours per night in bed
and they looked at having different
amounts of
time intervals between those five day
periods so like
some people did a five day sleep
restriction period then
one recovery night and then the second
five day
sleep restriction period other people
instead of having that one day recovery
between they had a three day recovery
and then others had a five-day recovery
and they were interested in that i'm not
going to talk much about that because
ultimately the results indicated that
recovery period didn't matter
basically at all but the thing that
jumped out to me this is like a very
quick research review but like
you would expect based on the previous
research and just based on
personal experience and anecdote like if
i'm sleep restricted i eat more
yeah as someone who has been tired
before
makes me hungry yeah i mean i and i have
less restraint with my diet
i'm much more likely to not only be more
hungry but also to be like you know what
none of my goals actually matter to me
now that i think about it
i'm just gonna eat like whatever feels
good at the time oh yeah you know
um so this is crazy so compared to
baseline
when participants were sleep restricted
and they documented their food intake
throughout these various periods
they increase their daily caloric intake
by 527
527 calories per day which is
insane that is so much that's a lot of
calories
they increased their saturated fat
intake by seven grams
okay like i'm not that worried about
that
decrease their protein intake as well so
like i i do notice when i am sleep
restricted yes
i eat more i do tend to skimp on protein
a little bit more so like this was one
of those studies where i
intuitively it made sense but man that
number is just
absolutely remarkable well their total
protein intake probably increased right
um because yeah it says it decreased as
a percentage of of calories yeah so so
they yeah but they eat a [ __ ] ton more
calories
that is true yes but uh but but you can
get in
a sense that it's not like they took
their their exact same food selections
and just ramped it up
yeah there's a little bit of a of a
skewing of the food choices as well yeah
they then say man it's so hard to keep
my eyes open
let's eat some chicken breast yeah yeah
so um
anyway i thought that number was just
absolutely baffling so
increase their daily caloric intake by
527 calories per day
along with some of those changes in food
preferences right so a little more
saturated fat a little bit less relative
protein intake per
per calorie consumed another thing they
noticed and this
again makes a lot of sense uh just based
on anecdote
the variability in this was remarkable
so
what what they found was the the change
in calorie intake within a person
was pretty consistent so it's not like
this is just lazy tracking that was
crappy like
these people had two different
restriction periods so they could
actually look at like
how consistent was your response to
these restriction periods
but the change in daily caloric intake
from baseline to sleep restriction
range from negative 305 calories per day
to 1639 calories per day
so like some people were like you know
what i would imagine because i've had
many experiences of sleep restriction
you ever get to that point where you're
so sleep deprived that you almost like
you almost feel sick and i don't think i
could even eat right now
yeah that was uh that was me the first
night in iceland remember
yeah yeah yeah where you're just like i
i'm so sleep deprived
that i can't stomach a meal like i've
been there yeah like some people have
that
that response naturally to sleep
restriction
and then other so like yeah i'm going to
reduce my calories by 305
per day but other people the the biggest
increase that they saw was
almost 1640 calories per day oh yeah
that was like me our second night in
iceland yeah so like it's just
absolutely remarkable to to not just see
the
the average uh response which was a
very notable increase in calorie intake
i mean 527 calories per day is
substantial but also to see that
variation and those numbers i should be
clear are from the first five-day
exposure
of sleep restriction the second exposure
that the results were actually even a
little bit more variable so
the the lowest uh or i guess the largest
reduction in calorie intake was about
515 calories per day
and somebody increased their calorie
intake by almost
1990 calories per day like and
that that's over a five-day period right
yes yes so they're averaging an increase
of 2
000 calories a day yeah i mean as long
as i'm interpreting this correctly
um and yeah which is i mean just
absolutely remarkable because when you
look at the the typical intake
of these folks uh i mean that's that's
almost just like saying
you know all those meals i normally eat
i'm gonna double all of them
like i mean because it's not like they
came in and they're like
you know they found the one group of
people who happen to be dreamer bulking
and everybody was averaging
you know 4 200 calories per day this
wasn't a sample of
you know competitive strong men at the
international level who are all eating
you know 4 000 calories per day
it's just normal folks who are eating
you know 2 300 calories a day and it's
like yeah
you didn't let me sleep and now i'm
gonna eat double that
like it it's pretty crazy now i would
expect
at a certain point eventually you'd
probably ease into it like
i wouldn't expect that you could double
your intake
in perpetuity i would expect that at
some point you kind of come back down a
little bit well yeah i mean there's
literally millions of natural
experiments on this like yeah
yeah new parents don't gain like 50
pounds during the first six months of
their
child's life that would be yeah that
would be
quite uh quite unfavorable for sure
but uh but yeah i mean sleep restriction
is bad news it's not fun i don't
recommend it
uh it's definitely a good idea to get as
much sleep as you can get away with
now the next thing i wanted to mention
i'm just going to do one more very
briefly
at some point i would like to dive even
deeper into this and maybe
do like a full-blown research review but
since this is a research roundup segment
i did want to just
note keep an eye on lactate i think
lactate is
is going to be a topic where we get a
lot more information over the next 5 or
10 years
about exactly what it's capable of doing
you know the the story of lactate is uh
it's a true underdog story at its core
so
lactate back in the day everybody looked
at lactate and was like
okay is it useless probably
doing nothing valuable and beyond that
is the singular
thing that totally screws us over during
high intensity exercise
like our kind of knee-jerk reaction to
what fatigue
is during like really high intensity
anaerobic stuff was like
you make this stuff called lactate it
sucks it fatigues you
there's nothing good about it it's just
like a thing of physiology that we wish
didn't exist is kind of the story of
lactate but then if you
biopsy someone's muscle
right after they do a weingate test it
tastes like yogurt
what that's not true okay
because like yogurt tastes like yogurt
because of the lactic acid
fair enough okay that's the culinary
joke for the day
uh but anyway the lactate story
uh changed you know we started to to
really look into it
i think george brooks i would say really
kind of led the way if memory serves
when it comes to
uh vindicating lactate a little bit but
we started to realize this is
actually you know a fuel source and it's
a substrate for gluconeogenesis and like
lactate is part of the recycling process
and it's not just a waste product it's a
really valuable thing that
that should be valued you know uh in
terms of being able to continue
sustaining exercise especially during
you know like repeated high intensity
bouts and things like that
and now the story with lactate is
getting even more interesting
because people are starting to look at
it as a signaling
molecule and so there was a new paper
within the past month or so called the
emerging role of lactate
as a mediator of exercise induced
appetite suppression
and this was kind of a short review
paper but they
basically summarized some emerging
concepts of how lactate might relate
to uh the suppression of appetite after
exercise so first of all
they pointed out there's some emerging
evidence that lactate can inhibit
the secretion of ghrelin uh from from
uh gastric cells and so ghrelin is
something that
you know will eat a meal and ghrelin
release will be quite low
like we're good we're full it feels
great
we're super happy about it but after a
while
a prolonged fasting period will start to
get hungrier
ghrelin production and release will
start ramping up and eventually our
brain will perceive that and say okay
ghrelin's getting really high
it's probably time to initiate a meal
that's kind of what ghrelin does so
if lactate truly can inhibit that
production and secretion of ghrelin well
that would be a pretty
notable thing in terms of the acute
hunger responses
after exercise they also in this review
paper present some evidence that lactate
can modulate
some of the signaling cascades of all
those neuropeptides in the hypothalamus
so
when you look at the hypothalamus and
the
the regulation of appetite and food
intake
there's a bunch of important
neuropeptides in the hypothalamus
and these neuropeptides really dictate
what we perceive as
you know hunger and satiety the
hypothalamus is really
calling the shots there so anything that
notably
modulates those signaling cascades
related to all those really influential
neuropeptides that's going to be a
pretty big deal in terms of
hunger and appetite regulation as well
and then they also mentioned in this
paper there's some emerging evidence
that
lactate can uh inhibit signaling
through the ghrelin receptor itself in
the hypothalamus so
the idea is that leptin would then not
only be able to influence the
production and secretion of ghrelin but
also the
interaction between ghrelin and its
receptor in the hypothalamus and again
the hypothalamus is a key
center that really regulates uh hunger
and appetite responses so
this is to be clear kind of an early
stage review paper it's like
it's not like one of those things where
we are telling the final story of
lactate and putting together this
you know completely bulletproof
rationale that summarizes everything
lactate can do
this is kind of the in the beginning
stages where we're saying
interesting we've got all this basic
research this kind of
more mechanistic stuff some of the
animal models stuff that's indicating
that lactate seems to be capable of
doing some interesting things here
and so this was kind of a let's touch
base and kind of go through these
emerging results
type of review paper so that's why i
said keep an eye on lactate i do expect
in the next few years we're going to see
more research related to lactate
and uh and appetite
and i also expect we're going to see
more stuff related to
to lactate and hypertrophy and anabolic
signaling as well
so there have been other papers
that have looked at lactate and how it
affects
pgc1 alpha signaling after exercise
uh which dictates a a number of kind of
biochemical
adaptations to training also looking at
how lactate affects
uh acutely some anabolic signaling after
exercise so
lactate is is kind of entering a
a new frontier of its uh its story here
where we're now aside from looking at
lactate as
a nice part of the fuel recycling
process now we're getting away from the
whole energy substrate conversation and
looking more at lactate as a signaling
molecule
looking at uh you know adaptations to
high intensity exercise looking at
potentially
anabolic processes following exercise
and there is by the way you know
i mentioned that this is uh largely
looking at some basic research some
mechanistic stuff but there is some
applied stuff
linking post-exercise lactate to
things occurring after exercise that
should impact
appetite so there was a study not long
ago is called potential involvement of
lactate and interleukin-6
in the appetite regulatory hormonal
response to an acute
exercise bout and basically they had
eight meal
eight males do uh four experimental
sessions so they did some moderate
intensity exercise some
vigorous intensity uh like continuous
exercise so steady state but pretty
intense
they also did sprint interval training
and then a control
condition with no exercise and they did
find that the higher intensity stuff
in this applied setting did suppress
ghrelin
and they also found that in some of
those higher intensity sessions
energy intake was significantly reduced
the day after the exercise sessions took
place so
one of the things i was interested in is
like okay well maybe there is this acute
signaling function
that you know these acute effects on
these different aspects of appetite
regulation
but again we're talking acute so maybe
five hours later
seven hours later eight hours later
maybe they're compensating for that
and consuming more calories right so
maybe there's an acute
reduction of energy intake or appetite
and then later
shortly thereafter we have a big rebound
but at least within that you know
next day time frame it doesn't look like
there is a notable
uh kind of compensatory increase in
appetite which
is far from uh painting the whole
picture like it's not like oh cool then
we're out of the woods there
um but at least it's promising right it
at least
dictates that we're not getting some
kind of
short-term response in a couple hours
that is is going to be
fully compensated for the next day at
least as far as these data
would indicate it's also important to
note in that study that the the
post-exercise change
in blood lactate uh was correlated with
the area under the curve
for ghrelin so like within that study
they painted a pretty nice picture that
uh high intensity exercise the different
modalities they looked at
did obviously impact the amount of
lactate production
and that did appear to directly
influence ghrelin
and it looked like you know the next day
even energy intake was reduced in some
of those higher intensity exercise
conditions so
there's a lot to be learned here but i
do think
it's at least promising some preliminary
evidence that lactate might have an
important role in modulating hunger and
appetite and that could be
a thing that you could tentatively try
to utilize and capitalize on so
if you are someone who's in a weight
loss phase and
uh you know you're noticing that hunger
is starting to become a little bit more
of a struggle
i do think that there's at least enough
there to say hell we're gonna have to do
some kind of
exercise anyway right like if we're
really pushing hard in a weight loss
phase
we probably have some degree of low
intensity cardio or high intensity
cardio
if you are truly just like if you really
can't decide
which one you want to implement on a
given day and you do happen to be
struggling with hunger
i don't think it's the worst idea to say
well maybe i'm going to lean a little
bit more towards some high intensity
work some more glycolytic work do some
sprint intervals
and see if maybe i get a nice little
bonus uh
where some of this lactate production
helps me manage my hunger
you know in the hours or even the day
after that exercise session
of course the main practical limiting
factor to keep in mind there is
if you're doing a whole bunch of really
high intensity glycolytic stuff
well that's going to make recovery
pretty challenging especially if you're
in a big caloric deficit
and you're doing a bunch of resistance
training so it's not like oh cool
that's an easy solution with no
downsides you know there's uh
there's going to be a fine balance there
where you maybe explore
some lactate generating exercise bouts
maybe push your intensity a little bit
higher
but you just got to be mindful of making
sure that your recovery is going to be
sufficient
as you incorporate those but i do know a
lot of people
who they get to a point in a diet they
want to keep pushing further
but they don't really want to drop their
calories anymore
and they tend to notice that some of the
lower intensity steady-state cardio
if anything maybe exacerbates their
hunger a little bit and we do see
uh some literature that there's a lot of
variability from person to person
but some people if you if you have them
do a bunch of
low intensity steady state cardio they
do have a lot of compensation
for that either by reducing non-exercise
activity or
increasing caloric intake it's variable
from person to person but there are some
people who
if you just ramp up their aerobic
exercise a little bit
they pretty quickly find ways to
compensate for that
by either reducing energy expenditure
increasing food intake so
i think there is a certain segment of
the population where this could
potentially be utilized effectively
in the course of a fat loss phase and do
you know anything about the the lactate
uh that connection between lactate and
uh anabolic signaling have you looked
into any of that research
uh there was a mouse study that found it
was
that that it like directly stimulated
muscle protein synthesis
yeah i mean it's all for now seems to be
pretty
basic science stuff like you know pretty
preliminary stuff a lot of
rodent models or even like in vitro work
but uh but yeah lactate like i said i
don't know if we
know everything about it yet well i'm
certain that we don't know everything
about it yet but
i think that's a story that is gonna get
increasingly interesting in the next
five to ten years
there was there was a paper that came
out
i don't know maybe like two months ago
or so uh
that looked at exogenous lactate
infusion
in humans uh following exercise i think
uh give me one second i'll find this
yeah while you're looking that up there
there
is some evidence that lactate promotes
differentiation of satellite cells which
we've talked about
a lot on the podcast before we've talked
about how satellite cells fit into the
whole hypertrophy
story there is some some evidence that
lactate um i'm pretty sure in an in
vitro study they basically
treated cells with lactate they did see
some increases in anabolic signaling
and interestingly they also had a
treatment
with lactate and caffeine that was
actually even more promising in terms of
some of the signaling they were looking
at
than lactate alone and then there was a
in vivo study with uh with rats where
they gave oral lactate with caffeine
and what they found was an increase in
muscle mass increased satellite cell
activity and
increased mtor activity but again we're
talking about rodents there
okay uh so i found the study um
so they had people do
unilateral knee extension exercise i
think
uh eight men eight women um
and while they were doing the exercise
they were receiving
uh an infusion into the exercising leg
either of a saline solution or a lactate
solution
uh they did not find that the lactating
infusion really did anything uh so they
looked at
uh mtor they looked at uh
s6k1 like several other anabolic
signaling molecules
they looked at muscle protein synthesis
so fractional
synthetic rate over a 24-hour period
post-exercise
again didn't really seem to do much a
caveat there
is that it didn't really seem like the
exercise was that hard
um so post post exercise blood lactate
concentrations
were 130 percent higher in the lactate
trial
but that difference is three versus
seven millimoles per liter
uh and like three millimoles per liter
of lactate that's like resting levels
right yeah
so yeah uh they may have just not
exercised hard enough to do
much of anything uh and and also there
was a big difference in blood lactate
levels um
but there wasn't uh in terms of muscle
lactate levels so it was
uh 27 versus 32 millimoles per kg of dry
weight
um so yeah that didn't really seem to
pan out but it it's
you know if if one were hypothesizing
that
actual muscle lactate levels were the
thing that made that made the difference
didn't seem like infusing lactate
directly really
much of it made it into the muscle
combined with
exercise that probably wasn't that
challenging in the first place
may not be surprising that it that it
didn't really seem to do anything but
anyway that's out there yeah and my main
interest level is not in like ooh can we
put it in a bottle
you know my main interest level is like
how does this
what are the implications for things
like blood flow restricted training what
are the implications for things like
making those decisions of how much of my
cardio should be high intensity versus
low intensity or
should i be even if i'm not trying to
lose fat
should i still be incorporating some
kind of glycolytic conditioning into my
program
i'm more interested in the lactate we're
actually generating in the active
musculature you know what i mean
but uh but yeah we'll see it should be
plenty of uh interesting stuff on the
horizon there
yeah i mean like you have to assume that
the lactate being generated in the
active musculature is what matters
because like
dude otherwise the ticket to gains would
just be
like to do a ton of neck training until
you wound up with sleep apnea
and then like you get [ __ ] huge
because your your lactate levels would
be elevated for eight hours a day
yeah without that would be really going
all
in on the on the idea you'd probably be
overeating by
you know 500 calories a day at that
point based on the previous study but i
mean
honestly sleep apnea is sounding better
and better
all right do you want to do another it
might be time for us to wrap it up here
uh do you want to do the muscle memory
yeah i'll i'll make this pretty quick
cool um yeah so we recently republished
a
mass article on stronger by science uh
about
whether the whether a myonuclear
mediated mechanism of muscle memory
that's way too much alliteration
uh basically whether uh
something related to the myonuclei was
likely to be the
the primary underlying mechanism of
muscle memory
um and the the article concluded that
you know
maybe it plays some role but it's
probably not the
driving factor uh and one of the reasons
why is that myonuclei permanence
probably doesn't exist to the degree
that maybe people thought it did
anyway if you're interested you can read
the article i think we talked about this
on the last podcast episode too
but anyway um so i wanted to talk about
muscle memory a little bit more since
that should be
fairly fresh on the audience's mind
so when i shared the stronger by science
article
on instagram friend of the pod alex
coleyri turner
commented like hey have you seen the
recent muscle memory paper
from marox lab i said no i hadn't so
uh he told me what to search i checked
it out and it was
very very cool so honestly though what
does alex know about this [ __ ] to be
honest
substantially more than i do
uh yeah so the the title of the study is
uh muscle memory
myonuclear accretion maintenance
morphology and micro rna levels with
training and detraining in adult
mice by morocco at all
and so i'm only going to be focusing on
the micro rna part of the study they
also
did look at satellite cells and
myonuclei a bunch this
was a super super cool and in-depth
paper
that would probably take 20-30 minutes
to do justice
i'm only going to be talking about
probably the biggest headline finding of
the study but if this is
an area of the literature that interests
you i'd highly recommend checking out
the paper
um but yeah so basically
uh this study suggested
that micro rna could uh potentially be
a mechanism for muscle memory uh and so
let's start with what is micro rna
so micro rna as the name suggests
is rna it's generally coded for
by about uh 22 base pairs of nucleotides
fun piece of trivia in case that ever
comes up at pub trivia
uh and essentially what micro rna does
is [ __ ] with gene expression so
um you know if it's been a while since
you've taken a biology class
dna is quote unquote red to make
messenger rna and then that process is
called transcription
and then messenger rna is quote unquote
read by ribosomes to form proteins
and that's called translation so
micro rna basically comes in
between transcription and translation
so it interferes with the messenger rna
before it can be read by ribosomes and
translated into protein so basically
it micro rna will have complementary
base pairs
to the messenger rna so you know
gene transcription occurs messenger rnas
are going out they say ah
i'm going to go find a ribosome and i'm
going to code for a protein
and then the micro rna comes in and says
nope
our base pairs match i'm going to bind
to you and then you're never going to
make it to that ribosome and
the protein that you're trying to code
for isn't going to get coded for so it
basically just like
[ __ ] blocks the translation process more
or less
that's what micro rna does uh and they
put it that way in the paper did they
uh yeah okay uh well i i mean that's
that's how it's typically referred to in
most textbooks yeah
um so yeah uh so
there is a particular micro rna
mir1 or micro rna r1
and it is a specific micro rna
that interferes with broadly anabolic
slash hypertrophic
gene expression uh related primarily to
the igf-1
akt pathway uh and so
basically if you have higher levels of
mir1 that's going to interfere with
hypertrophy and if you have
lower levels that's going to be more
permissive of hypertrophy
because you basically have less of this
specific micro rna that's that's messing
up the
igf-1 akt pathway
and so my mir-1
levels are known to decrease when a
hypertrophic stimulus is presented
which seems to be something that again
like i said is playing a permissive role
in hypertrophy
basically getting out of the way to let
these signaling pathways
uh progress more smoothly and so in this
study what they did
is they had uh four-month-old mice
they had several groups so one group uh
started at four months old underwent two
months of progressive
overload and so what they did is really
cool actually they used weighted wheel
running
so mice love to run on wheels and they
figured out a way to
add resistance to the wheel to kind of
mimic resistance training
so they progressively overloaded the
mice with weighted wheel running for
about two months
uh one group trained for two months and
then they just killed him
to analyze all of the things they wanted
to analyze
another group trained for two months and
then
was uh d trained for six months so they
were
harvested at one year then they had
another group
that was the first control group it did
not exercise but it was harvested at six
months old to match
the first group of mice that started at
four months old trained for two months
and then were killed
and then they had another control group
which was untrained for 12 months
to match the the d training group so
basically they had
two completely untrained groups of six
and 12 month old
mice and then they had a recently
trained batch of six month old mice
and a d trained batch of 12 month old
mice
and they looked again at a lot of
different things my nuclei
satellite cells they looked at changes
in the shape of myonuclei which i didn't
know that's something you could do
that's super cool
uh but the the thing they came away with
that seemed like it might be
an interesting candidate
to explain the the muscle memory
phenomenon
is changes in micro rna r1 levels
so uh they decreased when the mice
initially trained
and then when the uh the the mice that
trained for two months and then took six
months off
after not training for six months uh
their
micro rna r1 levels were basically the
same as the mice that
had just finished training for two
months so it seems like something that
is depressed when when
rodents undergo training and then stay
depressed for a long time
and you might hear ah six months that's
not that long that's like a quarter of a
mouse's lifespan that's like 20 25 years
in human terms so so very long-term
suppression of micro rna r1 levels
um and so since higher levels of
mir-1 kind of provide a break to the
hypertrophy process
if they're lowered by training and stay
low even after d-training
that could be something that's
permissive of more rapid hypertrophy
when uh i was gonna say people start
training again
when rodents start training again uh so
obviously that's the big caveat here
this is a mouse study
uh but to counter that i would say the
uh
the the myonuclear mediated mechanism
that everyone got excited about
that was also based on evidence from a
mouse study so
you know uh fight mouse studies with
mouse studies
uh so anyway that's obviously a big
caveat i'd wanna see if these
results replicated in humans obviously
but yeah this uh this seems to be
another
pretty interesting exciting candidate
that could
potentially do some of the work to
explain
the phenomenon of muscle memory good
stuff
i i think we rounded up a substantial
amount of research for this episode that
was quite a roundup so
you are now listeners you are now fully
informed and
at the cutting edge of science now to
play us out
i basically just want to vent a little
bit i'm pretty upset
so on a previous episode greg you you
told us that essentially crabs are not
crabs
there are a lot of things masquerading
as crabs
that have just kind of adapted they have
become
in the form of a crab but they are not
truly crabs
necessarily correct now i was in your
home i think
when i learned a couple years ago that i
had never had maple syrup
in my entire life ooh
during editing you should put a trigger
warning there for our canadian listeners
why just the the idea that i had not had
it correct yeah
because i'm a little bit self-conscious
about the way i pronounce syrup i've
never
i grew up saying syrup and then
everybody started saying syrup so i've
adopted it but i feel like it's wrong
it doesn't feel right you can say
whatever you want anyway so
apparently in america everything that
they're like branding as
syrup and they put like pancakes on the
label
i guess i never noticed they actually
they don't actually call it maple syrup
they just say like hey you know it's
like the
the stuff you put on pancakes and it
tastes kind of like maples or something
like i don't know but
it's just not real and i had no idea
it's just like corn syrup with like
caramel flavored or colored coloring and
stuff
but it's not maple syrup and i had no
idea so now the
the final blow that has just really uh
taken the wind out of my sails pumpkin
pie is
honestly one of my favorite desserts it
might be my favorite dessert
and it's you know america celebrated
thanksgiving like a week ago
it's one of the popular thanksgiving
desserts pumpkin pie
and one of my clients brought this to my
attention
and and she mentioned that it was from a
book called brave
tart iconic american desserts by stella
parks
but she basically let me know that like
apparently pumpkins are kind of an awful
way to make pumpkin pie
and that most people if they just just
did like a blinded taste test
would much prefer squash pie over
pumpkin pie like apparently
it's a much better candidate for making
that type of pie
in terms of its texture and flavor and
that's not news
apparent it was news to me but
apparently for the longest time in
america
they were like just selling everybody
like hey take this pumpkin puree you're
gonna love it
make pie out of it and the whole time it
was just some kind of non-pumpkin squash
that uh they're like just whatever we'll
call it pumpkin because nobody wants to
eat squash pie
but if we call it pumpkin they're gonna
like the pie apparently
the fda the food and drug administration
heard about this and cracked down and
said hey you got to stop
mislabeling this squashes pumpkin
because it's technically not a pumpkin
and then like libby's who makes a bunch
of canned pumpkin puree
they like got into the laboratory like
frankenstein style and created this
thing that they could call a pumpkin but
it's kind of like
in the gray area the biggest thing i
learned is that there's not a lot of
science
dictating what you can call a pumpkin
and what you can call a squash
it's a very murky gray area but the
bottom line
is within the last couple years i've
learned that none of the crabs i cherish
are actually crabs
none of the maple syrup i loved as a
child was actually maple syrup
and i thought i liked pumpkin pie and i
don't i've probably never had actual
pumpkin pie
so i'm just kind of frustrated we could
make pumpkin pie that might be fun
but now i'm learning that it kind of
sucks
and like you'd much prefer to have
squash pie so it's like i thought i
loved this thing that i actually
probably
wouldn't even like that much life's
tough man yeah
uh yeah so i i saw that you had this in
the outline and i wanted to
shake your faith in our food system even
more oh i'm just seeing this in the
outline
you taught me this already but yeah this
is awful yeah so
uh this first one i think a lot of
people are aware of
uh a lot of parmesan cheese
isn't actually parmesan or i guess like
the the platonic ideal of parmesan so
so parmesan is a term in the american
food system that can mean
pretty much anything when people think
parmesan what they probably have in mind
uh like the core product that it's all
based on
is called parmigiano-reggiano uh i'm
i'm sure i didn't pronounce that with
enough gusto
uh for our italian listeners i apologize
uh i am incapable of attempting to do
a proper italian pronunciation without
sounding very racist
uh so it's parmigiano-reggiano and
that's the best you're gonna get
anyway so that is the real deal it is
made in a specific
region of italy and any similar cheese
made outside of that region of italy is
not parmigiano-reggiano
and so most of what is sold as parmesan
in america
is not parmigiano-reggiano and the
the levels of it differ from things that
are decent simulacrums
so uh you know basically cheese made
um via a similar process but
outside of that region of italy um you
know and
it's gonna taste slightly different
because like
it's going to be exposed to slightly
different bacteria
and it's aged and different cellars but
like you know it's it's like a similar
cheese product uh and that's also like
a very small minority of the market um
most of the stuff that you would buy in
like a shaker bottle in uh
in an american supermarket either
doesn't have
anything that could even charitably be
called parmesan cheese or only like a
tiny tiny little amount
um basically any relatively dry
salty cheese you can just [ __ ] call
parmesan
uh and it's fine and so yeah like yeah
i eat parmesan pretty regularly but i
get it from the little shaker bottle
in the the grocery store aisle if you
told me
that like oh we did an analysis it's 80
sawdust
i'd believe it wait so were you saying
that with
knowledge of the sawdust scandal i i
i must have heard about it and then
decided i made it up because i was now
that i
am being called out in that actually i
think i have heard that it was a thing
but i assumed it was not true
yeah so the the two biggest sellers of
parmesan cheese
are uh great value like the walmart
brand
uh and kraft foods and uh
the the great value brand got in trouble
maybe like three or four years ago um
for having a product
product that they labeled 100 parmesan
cheese
and and calling it parmesan cheese is
not what they got in trouble for it was
like
i think it was a mixture of like
pecorino and like dehydrated mozzarella
or something like that
uh the actual cheese but it was ten
percent
uh cellulose wood pulp which like the
thing is that actually totally makes
sense because
uh if you don't coat the cheese and
anything it's gonna
just stick together like you you need
something to
keep those little like pre-grated
particles separated
uh for for a long shelf life uh but
anyway they got in trouble for calling
it 100
parmesan because it was like 10
cellulose by weight
yeah uh and kraft had gotten in trouble
for the same thing
like the year prior and i don't know
like i i don't think they changed their
product i think they just changed the
labeling
because they're like look we gotta have
the [ __ ] wood pulp in it like
we need the cellulose otherwise the
cheese is gonna stick to each other
um but yeah it's zero percent
parmigiano-richiano
i'm gonna assume that their compromise
to get through that scandal was not to
just change it to
90 percent parmesan related material
i'm gonna assume they went with
something else yeah i think they just
started calling it parmesan cheese and
that was fine just call it really good
parmesan
yeah period uh so yeah most parmesan is
not
the real parmesan the next is
some of the fish that you would get in
in restaurants primarily is not the fish
you think it is
uh so there was a study by a group
called oceana which
best i can tell is just like a general
ocean interest group
i guess uh like a big ocean lobby yeah
like
it's an it's an ocean adv advocacy group
so they ran a study from 2010 to 2013
um you know basically going around and
finding
fish that's like labeled as a particular
type of fish
and doing dna analysis to see like is
this the fish they say it is
um and it was mislabeled like
close to half the time and the two worst
ones
were red snapper which was mislabeled 87
of the time and white tuna or albacore
which was mislabeled 84 percent of the
time
so uh the things that were being labeled
red snapper
were basically just like any other type
of white fish
because red snapper is a white fish uh
i guess people think it sounds fancy and
they can't tell it apart from tilapia
but tilapia is really cheap and so
often times uh you'd go to a restaurant
and think you were getting red snapper
and it was actually just tilapia
uh or just like some other cheaper white
fish
um and then the the albacore is even
worse
because it was being substituted for a
fish called escolar
or you might also know it as snake
mackerel
and anyway so the thing about escolar is
it has
a particularly high wax content
in its meat so it has like some
some very interesting adaptations that
allow it to
uh metabolize and incorporate waxes
into its uh into its cells at much
higher proportions than most fish and
the thing is like
it tastes generally fine and it's not
gonna hurt you in small doses and so
like
if you think you're getting albacore
tuna uh
and you know you're eating maybe like
two or three total ounces of fish you'll
probably be fine
uh but escalar is like pretty well known
to give people explosive diarrhea
if they eat more than about like six
ounces of it give or take
um so that's that's just something to be
aware of uh
yeah if you go to and so uh the the
mislabeling issues
both with these fish and just like fish
in general um
didn't seem to be very widespread in
stores so if you go
to a store a supermarket and they say
like hey you're buying
whatever fish it is it is probably
actually that fish
but restaurant menus uh general
restaurant menus and
specifically sushi restaurants um
mislabeled fish way way more often than
than like stores in supermarkets did so
um
yeah be skeptical and especially be
skeptical of things
on menus called red snapper albacore
because there's like a five and six
chance that they're not
yeah and the really annoying thing about
that given that it's fish
is like some people make some pretty
calculated decisions
about what type of fish they're going to
eat because of the
you know for this type of fish there's
more
you know environmental contaminants more
more heavy metal accumulation than that
kind of fish or if you're just like
really tapped into food supplies like
overfishing issues
yeah so like a lot of people do make
very specific decisions about
what kind of fish they want to eat the
fact that there would be
mislabeling to that type of extent for
certain fish is pretty uh pretty
frustrating
yeah it's not great uh and then the last
one which like honestly i'm not mad
about because
uh you know it's mostly just like
screwing people who are
who are trying to be fancy but also
cheap
is truffle oil so if you
purchase truffle oil in the store and
it's not like a trillion dollars it's
not truffle oil
um so the vast vast majority of the
products that are marketed as truffle
oil which
i don't know how the [ __ ] they get away
with this like th
this strikes me as kind of like the
pumpkin thing that the fda would step in
and say something about
but most things that are labeled as
truffle oil are literally just grape
seed oil with a specific
molecule added uh so it's called 2 4
dithiopintane and it's one of the
like primary like very pungent
flavor or like scent molecules in
truffles
and so you know like it gives you a
truffle s
kit while also completely neglecting
every other scent and flavor compound
in truffles um but yeah like it's uh
it's literally not truffle oil like most
of them contain zero percent truffle
uh and i mean honestly like
th this is one of those instances where
like price is probably a pretty good
guide
uh just statistically speaking
for 99.9 of our audience
if you see a product labeled truffle oil
and you can afford it without taking out
a loan it's not truffle oil
uh it's it's just like literally
something else
yeah i mean that's like what i used to
always tell people when uh
when amino spiking and nitrogen spiking
and protein was like
very prevalent i was like well listen if
you're buying a finished delivered
product
with like a sponsored athlete on the
label that paid for marketing in your
favorite magazine
and they're selling it at less than the
raw material cost of whey itself
i'm skeptical like that's either an
extremely altruistic
supplement company that is just very
happy to take huge losses on that
or there's not that much protein in it
yeah you know you be the judge
yeah all right well i think that does it
for this episode as always uh thanks so
much for listening and we will be back
in a couple weeks thank you for
listening to the stronger by science
podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs for
all skill levels
and all schedules we hate spam just as
much as you do
so we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
you can sign up for the free newsletter
at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter or just go to the stronger by
science homepage and click the free
programs button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation
be sure to check out our facebook group
and our subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits
be sure to check with a qualified health
care professional
once again thank you for listening and
we will be back soon with another
episode of the stronger by science
[Music]
podcast
[Music]
do
[Music]
you